australia's shutting down again
australia is totally locking down
like it's going to be hard to leave your
home locking down
why australia is a pretty rough and
tumble place it was a
land mass settled by british criminals
it has flying foxes and gigantic spiders
and all sorts of things that are going
to try to kill you
and they survive because they're tough
people out there right
until the wuflu killed
one more person one more death
and the country shuts down good evening
within hours
sydney will be in the group of much
tougher restrictions
the premier clamping down on the
stubborn delta outbreak
with what she's calling a no regrets
policy
and this is why from a record 82
000 tests the state today recorded 111
cases
and tragically the third covert death in
this outbreak
a man aged in his 80s from the city's
south east
across greater sydney retail shops will
now close
a small list of essential stores can
remain open
construction sites across the city shut
down
and from midnight tonight 110 suburbs
across liverpool
fairfield and canterbury bankstown will
be sealed
shut that's 900 000 residents
who can't leave their area even for work
so you've got hundreds of thousands of
tests
well over a hundred thousand tests
you've got
a relatively small number of cases some
hundreds of cases and you've got
one more death the third of this
outbreak
but now just this one more one death
from this round of testing
so they're going to shut down everywhere
they're going to shut down whole suburbs
you can't go to work you were locked
basically in your home shut down retail
shops
because the lady running australia wants
to have
no regrets something tells me that the
people who can't pay their bills are
going to have some regrets something
tells me that people who can't go to
church probably going to have some
regrets
the people who can't be with their loved
ones while they die some regrets the
people who can't get married
some regrets the people who can't bury
their dead
some regrets you get the point people
who can't live their lives i think
are going to have some regrets in the
amount of time that it took
to watch just that clip from that
segment
on australia's channel 9 news
90 people died not from kovid
they just died because people die people
die all the time they die from a whole
host of causes
they die from heart attacks they die
from cancers they die from car accidents
they die from pianos falling on their
head while they walk across the street
they just
people die that's a fact mortality is a
fact of life that in modernity we try to
deny as best we can
but it's true all of life is a
preparation for dying
get used to it you will have a much
better life if you accept this fact
and because hanging concentrates the
mind he will also
want hopes look beyond just this mortal
coil
to to the metaphysical underpinnings of
our world but we can't do that in our
our age
so while the woofloo kills relatively
very few people very very few people as
a proportion of those who are dying
australia's shutting down again that
will happen here if
we do not exercise our political power
and push back
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself that's the name of this
entire episode you liked the clip you
liked the episode
yeah we actually do talk about eric
clapton on that show because eric
clapton is taking a firm stand
against vaccine mandates head on over
right now to the michael knowles show on
youtube you can get it on apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play myspace
xanga live journal and you can also get
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]